hey folks my name is jake and what
you're about to watch comes from
gamespot after dark gamespot's official
video game podcast
we were lucky enough this week to have
the incredibly talented shannon woodward
join us
you may know her as dina from the last
of us or elsie from westworld
if you enjoyed this little chat be sure
to check out the full interview by
searching for gamespot after dark on
your podcast service of choice
anyway let's roll the clip because you
said you've been acting for about 10
years was there a point when it
kind of occurred to you that you could
also take that talent into
video games or did you just hear about
last of us part two being a thing and
you really wanted to be a part of that
well i mean i i've actually been acting
my whole life like i started working on
nickelodeon when i was six
but i just have been like a lead of a tv
show
for 10 years like that's what i've been
like you know fully
working but um you know i always loved
games and i certainly liked to opine
about what i didn't like about game
performances
i you know and and that was just like my
general like
the things that would take me out of it
where i'd be like oh god why
why are they doing it like who is this
person and i think like for the last of
us the difference was is that like
ashley johnson's performance was the
first time i was like whoa
who is this like there was a naturalism
that like
not only really worked for this it
worked it served the story i found it
really moving and i didn't find it
performative
and like that's something that like i
just have it's my personal taste you
know like
that's because i come from a different
world and like so i really wanted to
you know be a part of that and i was
like oh let me try it i want to try it i
wonder if i can do it and by the way
there's plenty of times i've thought
oh i could do that and then i try to do
it and i'm not good at that
at all um but yeah i i did you know and
when they hired me neil and hallie were
really receptive to me being like i want
to be like funny like not disturbingly
funny i don't want to take things but i
really wanted that and
they let me do that and i you know i
think i
i've been trying to tax deduct my gaming
stuff
for a long time before that and my dad
was like you're gonna get in trouble for
this and i'm like no i'm not because i'm
gonna
i'm gonna work in on a game at one point
and then when i called and told him
i was like oh i got this job in this
game he was like i mean i'm happy for
you but i'm mostly just like shocked
that you've justified
the deductions and i was like made it
whole
you'd mentioned you were a big fan of
the original last of this what was it
like when you first walked onto the set
of last of us part two or the virtual
version
the medium um well i mean i think like
the
maybe the better way to answer your
question was you know first of all like
i knew the world so well like it's it's
really fun to go
read for something that has a world
that's already established because like
especially if you love it like you know
exactly what you're walking into
like you know how to speak you know like
what the
i don't like and i knew the game so well
and
i knew ellie so well that like it was
just very easy to go in and be like oh i
love her of course i do everyone loves
ellie you know
so if anything like that was really fun
was that was my second audition i read
with ashley the first one i actually
read with laura bailey because ashley
was out of town
shooting on blind spots so uh laura
played ellie for my audition the first
my first audition
and um but when when i read with ashley
then i was i was just like messing with
her i was just like
to the extent where like she talks about
this all the time like neil was like
going and like
talking to her like to try to get her to
mess with me then because i'd be like
all right
at this time i'm gonna go like this and
she was like whoa what
so it was fun because i knew the world
um and and i was just like i mean if
this is the only time i get to do this
like i want to try to like push it
around and see what happens and
i don't plan anything i do i just you
just kind of learn your lines and
know what what the general arcs of
things are supposed to be and then
i just kind of start at night and and it
surprises me it's kind of like jesus
take the wheel
i'm not religious it's just the only
saying that came to mind
so it was fun yeah next question is from
nbc
lucy do you want to read this one sure
uh question for shannon having worked
mainly as an
on-screen actor for tv slash movies what
are the differences when acting in a
game like the last of us part two
aside from the hundreds of ping pong
balls and would you like to take on more
video game roles in the future
um i think i mean the biggest difference
really
there's there are things i like better
in certain ways um
like i don't have to go through hair and
makeup it's not about
what i look like you know they're gonna
take my performance and turn it into
data
and like these other artists are going
to make it their own and i
you know again like i talked about like
what i really like about
filmmaking and all this is is how
collaborative it is so like
i find that to be really exciting and
interesting and
um and also there's not a crew of 250
people like up in my grill like they're
they're like 40 feet from me they're far
away from us
which is great so you know when ashley
and i are doing all those scenes like
it really felt like we were alone like i
could see people kind of in my
peripheral vision and we'd just be like
we guys scoot
but it's such a big stage that
it kind of just made it easier because
usually you know i've got somebody like
right here like right up in my face and
they're like okay well you just look at
this tape instead of looking at the
actor like there's a lot of tricks that
you have to do in order to like make
those things work and then also you got
like
a focus puller right next to the camera
and you got a dolly and there's a dolly
pusher and they're like scratching their
butts and stuff and doing all kinds of
man stuff
you know and you're like crying because
you you know
you miss someone then you're just like
the guy is scratching his butt truck
right now don't pay attention to it does
uh
so there's a lot of cognitive dissonance
that comes with you know performing that
way but
i didn't have to really do as much when
we were doing that and
and i really enjoyed it and also i mean
neil and halle are just such incredible
writers and like the storytelling and
the nuance of it also it took five years
so
like things really grew and sometimes
like
things became more nuanced and there was
a lot of time
to like kind of sink into it and to
where it was just like really second
nature
um but i
i would like to do other games i mean
i'm spoiled so i
and i like this narrative kind of stuff
a lot so
um you know i would i would love to do
it but
uh i think like it would have to be
something that
i felt really inspired by but there's no
lack of those things happening in games
right now so that's cool
how often are you going in across that
five years to film stuff
well it kind of depends you know because
you know there's two sections of the
game first of all so
there's i believe really in half of it
and
uh also ashley johnson was on a
television show that's shooting in new
york
so we would shoot when she was in town
which was like would be through the
summer and then also
on um usually like holidays and stuff
when she would come home to see her
family so like sometimes i would shoot
on westworld
and then go on the weekends to shoot the
last of us because
ashley was in town when it was over the
holidays or something
but so usually when she was in town it
was like a week a month
you know um
and that's about it because you know
they would take that stuff and then you
know they start working on
on those cut scenes and they start
building that stuff and
um but usually i think you know when
ashley was in town they would shoot a
lot of the stuff with us
and then when she was out of town they'd
shoot a lot of stuff with laura
um and all that so yeah and then after
that it's
vo for like a year like in the booth did
you have a pretty good idea of what the
story was early on or did
you figure that out later because i know
we were talking to
the some of the red dead redemption 2
directors and they were like yeah we had
no idea
what we what what what the context is
for a lot of these scenes because we
were just
given pages yeah no i i did yeah as soon
as um
as soon as they hired me neil
brought me into naughty dog and sat me
down in a conference room and did a
whole powerpoint presentation for
like three hours and walk me through the
entire game
frame by frame reference the whole game
not just my stuff but
everything but you know i'd already
signed an nda by the time we started but
also like that's neil like
the game it was already and things got
deep and there were a few
things that changed but not with my
story like and and some of that stuff
that changed
you know was really stuff that was um as
they started shooting they're like i
think this is wrong i think i think we
should i think this
this needs to swap or something you know
like but
i think that that only happened a couple
times um otherwise it's it's
i mean neil's a pretty extraordinary
storyteller
that's like the opposite of what you
hear about people in marvel movies who
get like weird rejection with west world
i'm like waiting for pages
waiting for pages like you know it
doesn't mean that the pages were done
you know the dialogue the scenes
themselves like they still
had to you know write the dialogue and
do those things but like
the the arcs of like how those stories
intertwined and like what it really was
like they'd been sitting in his head for
a long time in certain ways you know and
then i mean hallie was a big part of
that i think that that's what she really
wants a
naughty dog to start doing when we were
on the hiatus was to
help neil go through all this stuff like
because he had had a partner before on
the first game and he
wanted somebody to bounce stuff off of
and stuff and then they became an
inseparable pair
were neil and halley the kind of
directors that would
give you lines and be like this is what
i want you to say or were you
able to maybe not improv but kind of
change
things around or or like suggest ideas
yeah no we're very collaborative and
we're still very close i talk to them
all the time
um i think uh
we all just kind of work the same way
which is you know like there weren't
really things that like
didn't work i would just be like i kind
of want to like i have this
instinct to say like you know i want to
stop her from doing that and be like
that's good that's good try that
okay yeah you say that and then uh try
so sometimes like then he'll watch and
be like okay try saying
this instead like and that is all
collaborative right
that's like i have an instinct and he's
like oh that's an interesting instinct
why don't you say that here and then
ashley why don't you do this and then
in fact like when we were doing
interviews like people be like you know
what what lines did you write and i'm
like
i can't remember like i know that i did
it but i it all becomes so symbiotic
because we're also like
and also like i'm not the kind of actor
whoever gets like
i don't get like worked up if i'm like
my character wouldn't do i'll be like
this isn't
finished like i might not be seeing
something but like there's
but we never had that um
i i never really felt that i think the
only time i ever did there's like one
tiny moment after the grow house scene
where jesse comes in and we're like
putting on our clothes
and i was like i need him to turn around
i need i can't cannot do that it's
i have to protect her and he's like you
love him he's like your boyfriend i'm
like it doesn't matter
my loyalty is to this other person that
i just got nude
like he needs to turn around and he we
like he was like i don't understand that
and we had to like argue back and forth
about it
for like 20 minutes until i was like
neil i'm right i'm telling you
i i'm angry about it because that's the
instinct
and he was like and then once once he
understood it and we did it he was like
no that was a good note that was a good
note it makes sense and now watching it
it's like it would be so weird and i'm
like i was right about that
but it was like it was just like a male
female thing about about being like no
you don't understand what it would be
like to have a boyfriend walking an
ex-boyfriend what kind of your
girlfriend like you're still like
there's a boundary here man i love you
and stuff but back up
it's it's funny because i've played that
scene a couple times so like i know
exactly like
he i can see him like spinning around so
sweet about it stephen chang is such a
sweet actor and he was just like
oh oh yeah okay like he didn't like he
was like i i just like turn around he's
like oh yes sir
there's something wrong you know and
it's just so sweet that you're like
that's it that's perfect
you